cette association pro migrant milite
activement pour l'accueil de tous les
migrants et réfugiés la SIMAD fait
beaucoup parler d'elle parce qu'elle a
notamment milité en 2014 pour empêcher
l'expulsion de la famille mogoukov des
étrangers déboutés du droit d'asile et
dont l'un des fils est le tueur
islamiste du professeur qui enseigné au
lycée d'aras début octobre de son côté
l'association refuse de faire le lien
entre ce drame et la mobilisation
intervenue il y a 10 ans au nom du
respect des droits d'une famille il est
vrai que beaucoup d'associations de
protection des étrangers sont des
associations militantes qui évidemment
utilise toutes les failles du système
pour pouvoir défendre les étrangers sur
le territoire national c'est en
l'occurrence ce qui s'est passé pour la
situation d'aras fondé dans les années
30 par des protestants la simade ou
comité intermouvement auprès des évacués
a d'abord aidé à l'accueil de réfugiés
fuyant le nazisme aujourd'hui sa
principale mission est d'apporter une
aide humanitaire aux immigrés et aux
réfugiés elle est aussi un partenaire de
l'État en assurant notamment une
assistance juridique aux étrangers
retenue dans les centres de rétention
administrative la SADE est donc financé
pour moitié par de l'argent public soit
6,4 million d'euros en 2022 donné par
l'État mais ce 13 octobre la Simat
faisait aussi l'actualité car Marine Le
Pen était reconnue coupable de
diffamation après avoir accusé en 2022
les associations humanitaire d'être
parfois complice des passeurs
particulièrement à mayott où selon elle
la simade organise la filière
d'immigration clandestine en provenance
des Comores un constat partagé par le
collectif de citoyens comité des
intérêts de défense de Mayotte quand les
clandestins arrivent ils ont tous le
numéro d'un responsable associatif de la
simade ou d'une autre association
similaire c'est grâce à eux qu'ils
viennent la Simat se cache derrière la
loi pour organiser la conquête de Mayot
les commor très souvent la simade
intervient pour critiquer ouvertement la
position de la France en matière d'asile
et d'immigration soutien historique à la
cause palestinienne elle appuie le
mouvement boycotte désinvestissements
sanction condamné par l'Union européenne
au motif qu'elle renforce
l'antisémitisme en Europe et au
lendemain des atrocités commises par les
terroristes du Hamas le 7 octobre la
SIMA désignait uniquement les meurtres
et les prises d'otage comme une
offensive du Hamas rappelant le contexte
d'oppression généralisée et une
intensification de la
colonisation